this video is brought to you by nano
creators of virtual reality tools for
immersive molecular visualization and
interaction follow the link in the video
description to download nano man explore
molecules yourself
okay so secondary structure ordered
patterns or 3d Arrangements on localized
regions of the backbone of the
polypeptide chain
so we're specifically talking about H
bonds between a might hydrogen's and
carbonyl oxygens of the backbone and
when we say ordered patterns were
specifically talking about alpha helixes
and beta pleated sheets and in this
video we're gonna focus on Alpha helix
II specifically okay
so alpha helix C's so the Alpha helix is
this little right handed helix here it
looks like a little spiral and in ribbon
diagrams it's represented like this okay
and that kind of does look like a ribbon
okay and these alpha helixes are held
together by hydrogen bonds and the
hydrogen bonds are specifically parallel
to the axis of the helix and the axis of
the helix is basically the line that
would be running through that helix okay
so the H bonds with hydrogen bonds that
hold this helix together run parallel to
that line
in fact these little dashed blue lines
that I've got over here represent those
hydrogen bonds and those of course are
specifically the hydrogen bonds between
the amide hydrogen's and the carbonyl
oxygens okay so this dashed blue line
here or these dashed lines here are
basically that hydrogen bond okay which
again just to reiterate are running
parallel to the axis of this helix okay
now if you are groups that are on the
amino acids that make up this alpha
helix actually run sort of they stick
out perpendicular to the axis of the
helix right so they're sticking this is
the axis these guys are kind of hanging
out this way okay and that's actually an
important thing to note okay so here's a
closer look at the 3d version of the
Alpha helix coming from this protein
over here which is myoglobin so I
mentioned that the alpha helix is
right-handed it's a right-handed helix
which basically means that you can
follow the chain of the helix with your
right hand if you curl upwards
sort of towards your fingers whereas
their left hand you can't exactly do
that right this is not a left-handed
helix now another thing is that there
are approximately 3.6 amino acids per
turn which basically means that each
turn of the helix has around three and a
half amino acids covered so if we go
from here this is we got here at NCC so
if we go NC C and C C NC C and C C
that's about four amino acids right but
from around here to here there's around
three and a half so three point six
amino acids per turn approximately now
if I bring that ribbon back we can see
here that the the arc groups are
sticking out sort of perpendicular to
the axis of the helix right the axis is
going straight up and down like this
right and so we can see here that the R
groups are sort of sticking out
perpendicular to that now alpha helix
C's can have their structure disrupted
okay so and there are a number of things
that can disrupt the structure okay
including Heat bulky side chains
electrostatic interactions and the amino
acid prolene specifically so he is a
sort of sort of intuitive right he
disrupts hydrogen bonds and hydrogen
bonds or what hold it together the Alpha
helix right so if enough heat is added
those hydrogen bonds can be broken and
the Alpha helix can be basically
denatured okay that's pretty intuitive
but why is it that bulky side chains can
disrupt the Alpha helix well imagine an
amino acid with a bulky side chain for
example phenylalanine has the benzene
ring basically in its side chain let's
just say that these two R groups are
specifically the side chains of
phenylalanine so we have one aromatic
group there and then another one right
next to it and these groups are pretty
big and so they're simply going to
sterically hindered right they're gonna
be super close to each other like this
and they're gonna want to repel right
they're gonna kind of push away from
each other when they push away from each
other that's like
this alpha helix to bend in a way that
it shouldn't right so this portion will
be strained and that'll of course
disrupt the alpha helix
okay now sort of on a similar note
electrostatic interactions can cause
basically the same thing that happen so
let's just say for example these two our
groups are the sidechain for a sparked a
an aspartate has a charged carboxylate
group in its sidechain right Natalie
charge carboxylate group carboxyl a so
if we have two aspartate s'right next to
each other these negative charges are
going to repel alright so they're gonna
kind of push away from each other and
cause the Alpha helix to kind of bend
awkwardly in this way and that'll
disrupt the the alpha helix
sort of basically in the same way that
the the bulky side chains do right
they're just kind of causing the alpha
helix to bend in a way that it wouldn't
naturally okay now that's if we have
like charges what if we have opposite
charges and they would attract right so
what if I had an aspartate next to a
lysine and so we have a lysine with that
ammonium ion on it and so now we don't
have a situation in which the the
charges repel in this case they're
actually going to attract so they're
gonna actually bend towards each other
but that's still gonna put a strain on
the alpha helix right that the helix is
sort of gonna Bend in a way to allow
those charges to come closer together
either way we're putting a strain on the
alpha helix that wouldn't normally be
there okay
and so that's why electrostatic
interactions can disrupt and denature
the Alpha alpha helix okay now Pro lean
proteins kind of unique as an amino acid
because it's sidechain actually goes
back and binds to the nitrogen of the
ncc backbone of the polypeptide and so
when you have when you for example if
you have a prolene just sort of added
into the alpha helix that would that can
disrupt the ability of the hydrogen
bonds to basically exist in the alpha
helix and of course the hydrogen bonds
are super important in holding the
structure together that's one thing but
another thing is just that
that our group sort of just comes back
in binds and that that causes the helix
to sort of bend or turn in a way that
that is not supposed to and so prolene
is sets who sort of caused kinks or
bends to the alpha helix that denature
and disrupt its structure okay all right
so I'd like to further explain what's
going on as far as the disruption of
alpha helix ease so of course the our
groups here stick outward like this and
of course if they're big and bulky like
they are and actually well if we look at
these here we've got a leucine right
here and then we've got another leucine
up here and they're not very large
groups but if they're replaced instead
by phenylalanine large sort of aromatic
groups right next to each other then
they would repel and they'd put a strain
on the helix sort of spending it
awkwardly like that similarly if these
two residues were charged groups and
they were either I tried it to each
other or repel one another they would
also put a strain on the helix right if
they're attracted then that was sort of
straining helix in such a way that it
would Bend together like this and if
they were upheld then it would sort of
Bend the other way now of course if
there are a prolene in the chain the R
group sort of comes back and binds the a
my nitrogen so that causes two problems
one of course is that it puts a little
bend in the the actual turn of the helix
and on top of that the the R group
coming back and binding me my nitrogen
makes that night a my nitrogen
unavailable for hydrogen bonds which of
course are super important because they
actually hold this this entire structure
together let's quickly take a look at
these two different alpha helix ease
here we got this one over here to the
right and this one over to the left
they're both identical what we're gonna
do is when I hit this one on the right
and we're gonna highlight all of the
amino acids that are in it okay and
we're gonna mutate every single one of
those amino acids into a prolene so we
bring this mutate menu over and we're
gonna turn all of those amino acids to
proteins and nothing immediately happens
but we know probably messes up
structure of the helix so we're gonna
bring this minimization tool over which
is gonna sort of to some extent show us
what might happen with the bond angles
when we add those proteins in so clearly
right away we can see how the structure
changed right sort of flared out
everywhere
the atoms are sticking out more the
ribbon itself even sort of bent outward
a bit and that makes sense right given
that that prolene sort of adds these
kinks or these bends and kind of ruins
an alpha helix and you'd imagine of
course it that would also affect the
ability of this thing the hydrogen bond
hold hold together entirely so obviously
this isn't absolutely perfect right we
would expect this entire structure to it
to fall apart but this minimization tool
gives us an idea of what's actually
happening with those kinks and those
bends really messing with this alpha
helical structure right we can see here
just a closer look after removing that
highlight right here and here the flared
out compared to the left side so it's
pretty clear that that right ribbon is
different so that's basically it with
the alpha helix I do want to mention
that it's worth noting that the Alpha
helix can be disrupted by a multitude of
things and despite the fact that the
cumulative effect of the hydrogen bonds
holding together an alpha helix is
pretty strong there are a bunch of
things that that that can denature in
alpha helix and that's worth mentioning
especially is that they are less stable
relatively than then beta pleated sheets
which are less susceptible to do the
iteration as we'll see in the next video
hope that video is helpful thanks for
watching